he was telling us about the technical in
China them referees the dude is their
coach is like the national team coach or
he might be the leader of their army or
some early in the game they're probably
going to call offensive foul sure enough
ref is cheating soon as they call
offensive foul my dumb ass boots this
ball commotion next thing you know Boom
the ball's right back in my hand what do
I do kind of kicked further than that
they think I was [__] now I'm kicked
out of the game this is a charity game
yeah next thing you know the boss of
China whoever that is boss of China talk
to the rest but I think they end up
letting me play in the second half I was
fearful that they were going to take my
passport yeah you could get locked up
last place you want to be locked up in
China I think what do you think would
happen Phil you up with duck sauce well
I'm not I'm not spe Clon was fast as
hell like I'm on a gold tooth bro it
didn't matter I was f as a hiccup I was
high as giraff which is a dish in
China China for me is like a 7-Day top
what happens after that I start to
die